our top story sad breaking news tonight
in the Kate Steinle murder case the
illegal immigrant Garcia Zarate who
killed Kate Steinle on that pier in San
Francisco was acquitted just a short
time ago of murder and manslaughter
charges before he shot Steinle now get
this he was released from a San
Francisco Jail despite a federal request
that he be held for his six deportation
he already had seven prior felony
convictions let me tell you something
the mainstream media will never tell you
tonight it was San Francisco sanctuary
city policies that killed Kate Steinle
they did not obey the law they followed
these ridiculous liberal policies and
because of their stupidity and their
quote form of justice and caring more
about the rights of the illegal
convicted felons tonight Kate Steinle is
dead and her family has received no
justice here's the attorney for the
illegal immigrant right after the
verdict taking a shot at the president
really for those who might criticize
this verdict there are a number of
people that have commented on this case
in the last couple of years the Attorney
General of the United States the
President and Vice President of the
United States let me just remind them
that they are themselves under
investigation
by a special prosecutor in Washington DC
and they may themselves soon avail
themselves of the presumption of
innocence and beyond a reasonable doubt
standard and so I would ask them to
reflect on that before they comment or
disparage the result in this case I want
to go through some of the details today
and we pay very close attention here now
this family of the Steinle family have
been waiting more than two years for
this justice now Kate Steinle she was
armed and armed with her father on that
pier here you have a guy homeless at the
time claimed he found the gun with a
piece of cloth under his swivel chair at
a pier and then he says he picked it up
he accidentally fired it it ricocheted
and hit
Steinle in the back well we know a lot
more about mistahs already and that is
in fact that because he had little
experience with his guns as what his
attorney was saying but we did find out
some other facts tonight for example he
had been requested by the federal
government that in fact he be not that
he be handed over to federal authorities
they didn't do it the reason they didn't
do it is because of the sanctuary city
laws that are in San Francisco the same
laws now that have been adopted by the
Governor of California Jerry Brown in
this particular case you look at his
track record you look at all of the
deportations you look at all of the
felony convictions tonight America has
to ask a very important question tell us
tell us what good comes out of a
sanctuary City law people that never
respected our laws and our sovereignty
come into this country again and again
and again and again and again six times
after being deported after all those
felonies and an American young woman is
killed with her father walking on a pier
in San Francisco we're gonna have a lot
more michelle malkin joins us in a
minute now with a tax vote in the senate
looming many are wondering tonight what
tax reform could mean for their bottom
line here are the statistics as of now
this is important to every Forgotten man
and woman that voted in this election
this bill increases the minimum
deduction of $12,000 for individuals
$24,000 for joint filers it ends the
individual mandate penalty under
Obamacare thank goodness it removes the
alternative minimum tax
additionally the top marginal rate will
be lowered not enough in my mind thirty
eight point five percent perhaps the
most crucial part of this bill could be
in the dramatic reduction in the
corporate tax rates from one of the
highest at thirty five percent in the
world to just twenty percent and of
course the ten percent tax on
repatriation for multinational
corporations foreign cash
that means trillions potentially coming
into this country and factories and
manufacturing centers being built for
the Forgotten men and women in poverty
out of work now the question is what
does this mean for you here are some
examples the me
stream media will not show you according
to estimates a middle-income family of
four with around $70,000 in earnings
they can receive up to an estimated 60%
tax cut a single parent with around
$40,000 in earnings will likely see at
least a 50% reduction in their taxes
this is real money in hardworking
Americans pockets no the bills not
perfect
I would have preferred dramatic
across-the-board cuts like in the Reagan
era but it is an important starting
point lowering the corporate rate
spurring economic growth for decades
hopefully to come you listen to the
gloom and doom a Democrats this bill
will destroy the middle class and end
America as we know it watch the petty
display a predictable class warfare from
earlier today it's astounding if the
President and Republicans in Congress
set out to pass a middle-class tax cut
as they claim if that's where they set
out this bill completely misses the mark
they keep pushing it because it's a
payoff to their big donors if the
Republicans ran this thing through
they're going to explode the debt
they're going to raise taxes on
hard-working families if the deficit
goes up by 1.4 trillion dollars I
believe without any doubt that the
Republican Party will come down here to
the Senate and go to the house and say
my goodness we have raised the deficit
and in order to deal with that we have
got to cut Social Security Medicare
Medicaid nutrition education affordable
housing and every program that is
important you've got to remember for
almost a decade those same people you
see bashing this tax reduction this tax
reform are the same politicians that
gave us the quote economic wisdom of
Barack Obama but you know what what
about these Democrats well they're not
going to tell you is this what happened
under the Obama economy they'll never
tell you how bad it is we told you
during the last election under Obama the
slowest economic recovery from a
recession since the 40s 11 million more
Americans on food stamps eight million
more empower
pretty a homeownership rate at its
lowest in 51 years 50 million Americans
in poverty and an increase as I said of
8 million and get this Obama the only
president in history of this country
never to reach 3% GDP growth in the
country meanwhile since President Trump
was elected third quarter GDP just
yesterday was revised upward 3.3 percent
the highest rate in three years in
October
261 thousand jobs were created nearly 2
million now since President Trump was
elected unemployment a 17-year low
consumer confidence 17-year high median
existing home prices for all housing
types in October 2017 up 8.7% since
January the stock market today another
record all-time record based on that
alone who do you trust the Obama
sycophants that gave us these failed
policies their cohorts in the liberal
media their friends on the left side of
the aisle they want this bill to fail
when they failed all of us for 8 years
or what about this president that has
literally put confidence in the heart of
American corporations by getting rid of
Obama regulations and red tape we now
have seen what economic growth could
mean and what an economic turnaround
could be this bill must pass our
economic future depends on it
we're gonna discuss the tax bill also
later on the show and also bring you a
vote in fact we'll update you any votes
that happen in the Senate throughout the
night now we turn our attention also to
the ongoing nightmare that is NBC news
today it has been one day since Today
Show host Matt Lauer was abruptly fired
now multiple women have come forward
with shocking allegations of sexual
misconduct and abuse against the
longtime warning host some of these
allegations include exposing himself to
a staffer demanding the cheaper former
sector sacked give you an adult toy as a
present along with a note suggesting
that it be used in front of him and one
instance where Lauer summoned a married
staffer to his office where he had sex
with her until she passes out and then
Lauer reportedly took the woman to see a
nurse
earlier today Matt Lauer has issued an
apology with a caveats
that some of the allegations are quote
untrue or mischaracterize now more
damning tape also surfaced indicating
that Lauer's misconduct was going on for
a long while and may have been an open
secret at the peacock Network take a
look at this clip from Lauer's former
co-host Meredith Vieira where she talks
about his in office bag of sex toys
what's this have to say I run into your
office once do you remember this yeah
snooping and you had a huge bag of sex
toys and you do remember this away okay
can we explain what happened as you were
there we had a guest on the show who was
a what was she a sex therapist and so
when she left I think you did the
segment actually then when she left she
gave each of us a shopping bag of stuff
get a bag as Ruth story also this clip
Matt Lauer an awkward interview with
Anne Hathaway where he obsesses over a
quote wardrobe malfunction let's take a
look and Hathaway good morning nice to
see you I'm Matt seen a lot of you
lately I'd be happy to stay home but
let's just get it out of the way you had
a little wardrobe malfunction what's the
lesson learned from something like that
other than that you keep smiling what
you always do well it was obviously an
unfortunate incident yeah so so let's
turn I've ever heard and earlier today a
reporter from variety told CNN that Matt
Lauer's behavior was well known by NBC
employees take a look high-level
executives were told about his behavior
both current and prior her sources say
it wasn't even considered a secret it
was known by many employees at the Today
Show including some employees that have
gone on television and said publicly we
had no idea according to our reporting
some of these some of the other
personalities and on-air personalities
were aware of these allegations
according to our sources the co-anchors
were aware of some of these allegations
and so they're having trouble reckoning
what some of these anchors said in
private
conversations versus what was said on TV
yesterday current anchors or former
echoes this isn't the end of the story
now we believe that there will be more
women coming forward and will believe
there will be more evidence about who
knew what when that will come out in the
reporting in the days to come okay what
did the folks at NBC know when did they
know it NBC News chairman Andy lack is
quote deeply saddened by this turn of
events but our Lauer's actions really a
turn of events or just business as usual
for the embattled former morning host
and then there's the current fake news
CNN chief Jeff Zucker he served as the
head of NBC News during many of Lauer's
allegations of misconduct
soccer's now saying the quote I didn't
know this Matt so was sucker in the dark
or did he turn a blind eye these
allegations against Matt Lauer they need
to be investigated fully but if true
those who knew about this and possibly
enabled this behavior should be called
out now with allegations of bounding
while all of the stress at NBC News
seems to be getting too crazy liberal
Joe Scarborough especially after Trump
made this accusation in a tweet so now
that Matt Lauer is gone when will the
fake news practitioners at NBC be
terminating the contract of Phil Griffin
he runs MSNBC the conspiracy network and
will they terminate low ratings Joe
Scarborough based on the unsolved
mystery that took place in Florida years
ago investigate well earlier today
liberal Joe had a complete mental and
emotional breakdown on national
television watch we are facing a
showdown with a nuclear power and you
have somebody inside the White House at
the New York Daily News says is mentally
unfit that people close to him say is
mentally unfit that people close to him
during the campaign told me at early
stages of dementia when is this the
right time to talk about a mentally
unstable president in the White House
and a nuclear showdown with another
unstable madman in North Korea everybody
around Donald Trump knows he's not
stable everybody around Donald Trump
know
he's not stable Minelli everybody I know
for a fact that's not true by the way
now we have dr. liberal Joe he's
diagnosing on television in the morning
now instead of worrying about a nuclear
holocaust with North Korea may be
liberal Joe maybe should worry about
getting his emotions in check and not
letting this obsessive compulsive
non-stop hatred of President Trump send
him over the edge
Joe you need help there's a lot more in
terms of serious news that you should be
covering by the way no one should worry
that liberal Joe and his allegations by
the way and its friends in the
Democratic Party
well maybe Joe you should be asking
questions about that because the Senate
Ethics Committee has now opened a
preliminary inquiry into the groping
allegations against Senator Al Franken
now this comes after yet another woman
an Army veteran has come forward to
accuse Franken of groping her during a
USO tour no three and while Franken
faces even more allegations his
colleagues in the house well John
Conyers in particular he's now facing
growing calls to resign after multiple
sexual harassment allegations and
accusations including involving a
taxpayer-funded settlement even as
longtime defender Minority Leader Nancy
Pelosi
she's miraculously now done a complete
180
today she's now calling for Conyers to
step down watch this the allegations
against congressman Conyers as we have
learned more since Sunday are serious
disappoint disappointing and very
credible it's very sad the brave woman
who came forward or owed justice I pray
for congressman Conyers and his family
and wish them well
however congressman Conyers should
resign remember this comes less than a
week after Nancy Pelosi defended Conyers
called him an icon talk about due
process
I guess now she suddenly remembered that
she considers herself a champion for
women's rice rights and meanwhile John
Conyers who's now hospitalized with
stress-induced symptoms apparently is
remaining defiant he's still denying the
allegations earlier today his lawyer
fired back at Pelosi watch this
but it's not up to Nancy Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi did not elect the congressman yes
she sure as hell won't be the ones to
tell the congressman its ally we'll have
more on these Democratic scandals that a
play-in plaguing them later tonight in
the show but first we have a lot more on
our top story Kate Steinle killer found
not guilty now walking free Kate Steinle
killed back in July of 2015
walking arm-in-arm with her father on a
pier in San Francisco shot and killed by
an illegal immigrant Jose Garcia Zarate
this man had seven prior felony
convictions for involving narcotics this
was his facing of a sixth deportation at
the time he shot and killed this
innocent woman the illegal immigrant
said he accidentally killed her he said
it was an accident that the bullet
ricocheted off the concrete and hit Kate
Steinle
his lawyer says he found the gun just
moments before he shot her and it gets
worse he says his client had never fired
a gun before and got scared after it
went off what did he do he threw it off
the pier and they found it the next day
and as I said at the top of the show
sanctuary cities tonight those that
support them they are to blame for the
death of Kate Steinle with reaction